good morning John happy birthday I sent
you your birthday present and you sent
me a picture of you wearing it I'm
really glad that you like it
you're stunning 41 year old band and I
guess that's like the middle age but who
cares what does that matter when you
have done so many wonderful and great
thing I'm proud of you John so I wanted
to create a special video just for you
to celebrate your career by presenting
to you your life as decided by the hive
mind these are the top 10 gifs that came
up when I searched for your name in
Twitter's gift search number 10 doing
that giant squid of anger cuz John you
mad sometime this might even show up
when you search for anger so there's
probably lots of people who are just
posting this angry nerd and don't even
have any idea who you are I'm a nine
likewise from the same video even a
captioned guys this one is probably used
by people who are angry on the internet
but a quick shift for number eight you
doing your happy dance which we don't
see enough of these days not because you
aren't happy of course but because
you're old and it hurts to move too much
number seven you're angry again though
to be clear this I don't think has
anything to do with you I'm guessing it
has something to do with the Internet
number six now you're frustrated but I'm
gonna give this jiff ten out of ten
because I know that you actually injured
yourself while filming this and I admire
that dedication number five know a
little bit this is great because maybe
people are introducing a little bit of
nuance into their internet discourse and
they're using you to do it John no but
yeah maybe song number four sarcastic
party popper I can see why people might
use this one but it's kind of a shame
since there are so many legitimate
enthusiastic party popping moments in
your career and only one sarcastic one
but that's the one the internet picked
up on but it is a really good life so I
can't complain
number two ten out of ten I love this
girl and I want there to be a database
that shows me every time this Garf was
used because I want to see why people
are using it but I do love it so much
the fact that this is number two it kind
of restores a little bit of my faith in
the internet John and finally number one
the top John Green goof on Twitter it's
you sniffing your own book which is now
once again destroyed my faith in the
Internet what's going on why are people
using this why is this good what's
happening
that's what you people want that's
actually pretty good of course I got to
hit you with some honorable mentions
these days very useful gifs this one
Congress this one surprised Putin now
that actually has audio if you use it
right yeah anytime you do something dumb
it's high points in my book and of
course this one where you're scared of
squirrels I love it so much Jon what a
wonderful and wide-ranging life and
career you have had thus far and I'm
sure that there will be many more joyful
moments for you in the future
I am very nearly on my way to VidCon
Australia ah I still think it's
available if you'd like to see me or a
number of other very cool creators we
got a super great memorable special
VidCon in the u.s. this year so I'm
super excited to go have more of that in
Australia and then in February in London
we also just finished the pod con
IndieGoGo campaign two days ago and I
mean if ever I don't know anybody's ever
gotten closer to hitting the goal
without hitting that goal but two
hundred ninety nine thousand five
hundred sixty nine dollars is a win for
me I think we can make up the difference
pod con tickets are on sale now at pod
comm you can find the links to all those
things in the description and Sean happy
birthday I'll see you on Tuesday